what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
have some pretty big spider-man
no way home news today we actually have
two different pieces of news today that
of course i'll break down
one in regards to the trailer for no way
home and
when to expect it and another involving
a pretty big plot leak
concerning a very very specific
character or
two specific characters and their
important role that they're going to
play in spider-man no way home
spider-man no way home is about eight
months away and
people are starting to wonder when
exactly are we going to get the first
teaser trailer for it and what to expect
in the first teaser trailer
i'll talk about that in this video but
quick heads up i will be going live
today at about 4 p.m
pacific time we'll be talking about more
spider-man news more mcu news and i'll
be announcing the captain america shield
giveaway winner while i'm live so be
sure to come by
and check it out and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all of the latest marvel
news
so in terms of the spider-man no way
home trailer we haven't really had much
news about it at all
except for when sony actually kind of
played us telling us that we were going
to be getting our first
look by the end of the year and that
obviously didn't happen thanks sony
but now since most of the filming is
done with spiderman no way home and
they're heading into post-production
they're going to have footage that
they'll be able to use for a teaser
the only question is when and that
answer could be
pretty dang soon according to grace
randolph who was the host of beyond the
trailer we could be getting the first
teaser for spider-man no way home in
june or july
now very recently grace was right about
the chongqi
trailer she reported when it was coming
out and it was indeed accurate she was
right
now grace randolph has been wrong about
some things in the past but she has
interviewed people like paul bettany
elizabeth olsen
zack snyder himself and has been right
about a lot of things in the past as
well
so she does have credibility and if one
thing is certain she definitely does
have some sources
and so right now she is claiming that
the teaser for spider-man no way home is
going to be coming in june or july
so if that is true we only have a month
or two to wait
and the math of this is kind of adding
up anyways it's about eight months or
seven months before the actual release
of the movie and that's usually when
they put out a teaser trailer for it
and if we're lucky we could actually get
the teaser at the beginning of june and
then an
official trailer for it at the end of
july but that kind of all depends on
when they release the first
teaser for it now what can we expect in
the first teaser i know a lot of people
want to see
tom holland spider-man with the other
spider-man andrew garfield
and toby maguire of course everybody
does if they are indeed in the movie we
want confirmation of this but i don't
think we're going to get this
in a teaser i do however think that we
are going to be getting a teaser of
the multiverse starting to fall apart
and it is possible that we could see a
character like
alfred molina's dog och or jamie foxx's
electro
and probably an appearance from doctor
strange because of course he's confirmed
to be in the movie but i think they're
going to be saving those really really
big cameos toby and andrew for the
actual trailer release
but hopefully that is actually something
we'll be finding out soon and hopefully
the teaser trailer is indeed going to be
released in june or
july according to the report from grace
randolph and of course as i mentioned in
the beginning of the video we do have
a new plot leak today it's actually a
report coming from a pretty credible
source the hashtag show
now before we dive into this there is
something that you need to know
sony and disney recently made a new deal
with each other
last week they finalized a deal that is
going to bring all of the spider-man
movies to disney plus
and the hashtag show is reporting that
they can exclusively share
that marvel studios now has shared
rights with a huge character from the
spider-man universe and that character
is the one and only
norman osborne who we have been talking
about appearing in spider-man no way
home for some time now
and it looks like the leaks that some of
these people have been posting to the
online forums could
actually be true as it seems like there
are going to be
two norman osborns in spider-man no way
home one from the sam raimi universe and
one from the mcu however according to
the hashtag show there is a twist
they report that we know norman osborne
played by willem dafoe in the raimi
films is making his marvel cinematic
universe debut
they say that marvel studios plan was to
bring willem defoe as the primary
villain for spider-man no way home
but they can exclusively share that
because of this most recent deal with
sony and disney there now exists
a separate version of norman osborn in
the mcu
they say that peter will begin to
research his earth's version of norman
osborne after fighting
with willem dafoe's green goblin but
there's a twist
he's seemingly not an awful guy he has
political aspirations
makes charitable donations and even
supports the avengers
they're playing off the idea that it's a
different earth and no villain or hero
is guaranteed to be on the same
path now side note before we dive into
the rest of it
this is seemingly what marvel is kind of
dealing with loki
loki with the tva is going to be
exploring different
universes different timelines different
realities and they're going to be
exploring different
loki's and some of these loki's are
going to be on very very different paths
just judging by what we've seen from the
trailer female loki seemingly wants to
destroy the world or she
wants to help it we're not really sure
about that one it looks like one could
be the ruler of asgard one seems to be
db cooper the point is there are going
to be different loki's and they're all
going to be down
different paths so the fact that they're
going to kind of express
this about the multiverse kind of makes
sense and it could be kind of nice to
see
a good norman osborn but only because
they're going to also
include a bad one as well but the report
goes on to say
yes that means a different mcu norman
osborne
what marvel has wanted to do is explore
norman osborn more
and without putting him in a goblin
outfit at least not right away
start to peel back the layers of his
villainy this will take place over the
next three to five years as marvel
begins to set him up as a major villain
for both spider-man
and the avengers going forward now they
sort of in the report talking about how
this wasn't finalized until last week
when the new sony and disney deal went
down
however the more that we start to find
out about what exactly is happening in
spider-man no way home the more i'm
starting to think that the old avengers
tower in downtown new york which clearly
somebody bought
as we saw in spider-man far from home is
most likely norman
osborne's oscorp tower if this report
from that hashtag show is correct then
norman osborne exists in the mcu
and apparently he has supported the
avengers could that possibly mean that
he
is the one who bought the old avengers
tower is that the support that they're
talking about i think it could be and i
think it could be a
cool way to kind of tie him into
everything and not to mention this could
definitely lead towards the dark
avengers
specifically because this report states
that norman osborne is
a political person which means that he
probably has some government ties not to
mention he makes government-grade
weapons but that's kind of how the dark
avengers start norman osborne kind of
becomes a hero
instead of a villain at least he's
viewed that way after the skrull war and
the government assigns him as the leader
of the new avengers team however norman
osborne
isn't ever really a 100 good guy
which is really what this report says it
states that over the next three to five
years we're going to kind of learn more
about norman osborne and kind of follow
him along his journey on the path of
villanry
but it's definitely going to be
interesting to see two different norman
osborns in the mcu we have several
people who have reported this at this
point in time so this is looking to be
more and more of a
pretty confirmed thing i should also
mention that in the hashtag shows report
they mention a fourth
spiderman film they have heard news
about this specifically a fourth
spider-man film for tom
holland tom holland has already stated
that if marvel wants to do a fourth film
he is absolutely going to do it and with
a new deal between sony and disney i'm
sure there are some more tom holland
contracts involved so the future is
looking bright for our good friend
spider-man
except for the fact that he's kind of
going to have to face two different
norman
osborns at two different points in time
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below
is this something that you'll be excited
for let me know and don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date
with all of the latest spider-man news
and of course other marvel news as well
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you